there are only a few ideas that had as
much of an
impact on education as those of john
dewey
to understand his ideas let's imagine
dewey reappears in the modern world
with the mission to implement his
theories in a conservative school
dewey championed learning by doing also
known as experiential learning
he observed that children learn better
when they are actively engaged
because they are immersed in the present
and not a distant future
such as final exams in biology
students don't read books but instead
grow
plants harvest fruits and then feed them
to snails to see what happens
sometimes things work out sometimes
accidents happen
whatever the outcome the students take
notes of their observations
and form rich memorable experiences
at the end of each class they summarize
their learning
and turn to discussions
the discussions prepare the students for
life in a democratic society where
decisions ought to be based on
reasonable arguments through the debates
the children learn to formulate their
own ideas
convince others and learn to see the
world from a different point of view
in one discussion some started to argue
that school uniforms
limit self-expression and that they
should be abolished
dewey who believe that schools should
prepare children for life itself
and serve society as a force for
innovation and reform
encourage those students to start a
petition
to find out for themselves if real
social change is possible
classes are interactive because dewey
believes that interaction with the
environment
is essential for the learning process
since education is an experience that is
subject to constant change
passive recipients of knowledge on the
other hand learn
very little if anything at all the group
who started the petition
present their ideas to the teacher and
start a dialogue that expands their
understanding
and underlines their learning
learning is interdisciplinary do we
believe that continuity
is critical to comprehension and that an
interdisciplinary education
allows students to build on what they
already know
which strengthens their understanding
what they observed in biology
is being calculated in math written
about in
english and put into images through the
arts
this provides the students the
opportunity to learn how things are
connected
to the brain this process is more
effective
because it can link new knowledge with
previous experiences
and build stronger mental models
[Music]
do we believe that when societies
calculate the price of education
they shouldn't only look at the cost of
school buildings
teachers salaries and other resources
they should also consider the costs of
all the hours
input by the children because the
children are the future of our society
and human progress their time in class
ought not to be wasted
it is thus the school's responsibility
to be a playground to practice a future
we wish to see so when the kids grow up
they can go and create it
about education dewey famously said
it's not a preparation for life
education is
life itself the group that sought dress
code reform
gained a deeper knowledge about the
topic and were able to develop
good arguments they printed their
demands on banners and tracts
and discussed their ideas with everyone
until the day
the majority of students and teachers
had signed their petition
eventually the petition was presented to
the principal
and a new school rule was passed
dewey's ideas were not always popular
during his time
and while we made some progress in
education over the last hundred years
is the situation really any better today
what do you think did you experience
learning by doing in your school
and does your school encourage you and
your friends to engage in
social reform and create the future we
wish to see
please share your thoughts in the
comments below
[Music]
sprouts videos are published under the
creative commons license
that means our videos are free and
anyone can download
edit and play them for personal use and
public schools
governments and non-profit organizations
can also use them for training
online courses or designing new
curriculums
to help us stay independent and support
our work you can join our patrons and
contribute
just visit patreon.com sprouts even one
dollar can make a difference
you